I'm pretty sure I owed heed this past
weekend on adrenaline but let's talk
about it let's review doom eternal let's
rip it down doom eternal so do me turtle
is a first-person shooter the sequel to
the 2016 doom games I was a huge fan of
cuz I've just I've it's doom in Doom
eternal hells invasion of Earth is well
underway and you the doom Slayer stand
between them and us as our last best
hope
dooms a classic and with doom eternal
it's clear that doom continues to be a
spearhead we're getting to the gameplay
I'm just gonna briefly touch on the fact
that the game looks gorgeous the
graphics are amazing the sceneries out
of this world movies rarely have
backdrops as epic as this game the
framerate is smooth as silk I mean just
really you want to hear my opinion on
the gameplay yeah this game is it's fast
it's a faster more aggressive version of
doom compared to even the 2016 doom the
2016 doom was a cakewalk not that it
wasn't fast and aggressive this is just
more so the game gives you what you need
to survive you just need to learn to
utilize in that there is a learning
curve especially before you're all
beefed out you have all your upgrades
when you're just you know just base
level doom Slayer yeah you might get
your ass kicked a few times just funny
cuz then when you are beefed out you go
back to that level just wipe the floor
with them you feel like a god by the end
of this game I wish the intensity is
amplified by the music music in this
game you can't help but just audibly it
gets your adrenaline up which is perfect
you want a lullaby playing again you'd
be easy to have really intense music
that doesn't really fit music in this
game solid and it serves to elevate and
amplify the experience the apex of that
feeling is from the Slayer gates the
Slayer gates are amazing I do wish that
when you beat a Slayer gate you could
just pick it from the menu and just do
the Slayer gate from the menu rather
than having to go back into the level in
this stage and find the key and find the
Slayer gate and basically replay the
level regardless the Slayer gates are
the most fun I had in this game if you
like a room full of a lot of aggressive
demons of all different sorts all
different types Slayer gates are the
culmination of that like if doom eternal
is interesting
Slayer gates are the most interesting
man in the world it's crazy a man I
loved him I loved all the Slayer gates
the dash and the chainsaw are
instrumental in your survival and doom
eternal if you don't use the - you're
gonna die in 2016 doom the chainsaw was
cool it was nice to get ammo back but I
never felt like I needed it it's not a
necessary mechanic in the game but in
Doom eternal using the chainsaw to
replenish your ammo is a necessary
mechanic of the game for your survival
and you consciously use it for that they
do a good job of just having those
little stragglers just walking around
you like are you are for ammo band as
you play you find secrets you unlock
mods on your guns like each gun has two
different builds for it just like 2016
doom and I got so used to the 2016 doom
weapons or I was like I love those
weapons so much it is this one gonna
hold up the weapons in this game are
sweet they do a great job at giving you
everything you need weapons weapon
variety there's enough in this game to
fit anybody's plays done like I said
before certain enemies is like this
weapon and this build is best for them
but I mean I'm a creature of habit
personally so the shotgun that shoots
the sticky grenade that sticky grenades
a lot of what I use and you're like
alright let me rock the ballista mmm
shoots out a horizontal wave that just
cuts enemies in half you're like oh god
but it still balances it out because
it's a really powerful gun but when it's
charged up you're walking like your feet
are just in mud so you know pick how
you're gonna use it point is as a
self-professed creature of habit when I
ventured into other weapons and other
weapon builds I found new different ways
to play and I had a blast doing it you
might find one weapon you prefer but it
doesn't mean the other weapons are
useless speaking of new things to the
table not just the weapons but we have
new enemies as well 2016 doom the
enemies were generally enemies that we
knew from old doom but now new graphics
it's awesome hey now stay burnin new
enemies in here again I'm like are
they're gonna hold up yup the enemies in
this game are amazing that kind of
variety you need in a doom game you
can't just have everything from before
all right well now we have new levels
that would just be called 2016 doom DLC
you need new enemies and the new enemies
in Doom eternal they give some good
flavor I mean they have a cyberdemon
he's not called the cyberdemon but he's
totally the cyberdemon
mojo from x-men looking [ __ ] who makes
shields in front of other enemies making
it harder to kill them or how about that
one dick he's just like shrouded in fire
and he's just raising enemies from out
of nowhere takes an ungodly amount of
hits to kill him but they're not gonna
stop coming unless you do these new
enemies mix with some of the old makes
for a good roster of demons that's just
fun to rip and tear through I love doom
encounters so much
it's just 2016 doom and now I'm gonna do
it with doom eternal I would just if you
had a bad day just pop it on below some
steam and the enemies now have exploits
which again I really appreciate it like
the revenues you know they have the
cannons on the shoulders you shoot the
cannons and blow them up and then they
won't have a candidate anymore man
caboose has flamethrowers forearms blow
those up he no longer has them but some
of the weapons that might be best to
shoot the flamethrowers off with the man
caboose or shoot the cannons off of the
revenants it might not be the best
weapons to kill them so even though the
game keeps you on your toes you got to
change it up that level of prioritizing
where it's like that enemy takes more
hits but I can blow up his cannons right
now then maybe concentrate on these
other guys and then come back and finish
him off keeps the game fun fresh and you
can do it different ways every time you
pop the game up then even after all that
you want to do the endgame cleanup you
got yourself some solid endgame cleanup
got a lot of hidden stuff a lot of
secrets and you unlock cheats where when
you replay the level you can just
activate the cheat some of those cheats
are amazing one of it has like cheers
from quakecon so when you're
annihilating a room of demons and all
these cheers from quakecon or happening
makes you feel like a rockstar makes you
feel like a boss and it also makes it a
bit more enjoyable going through these
levels for you know two or three times
trying to get everything because these
levels are no joke these levels are
enormous not just a pop into one level
or I do it it's like each level feels
like two or three levels which makes for
a lot of game you're getting your
money's worth that's for sure but for
doing the endgame cleanup it's like yeah
I can go for some unlimited ammo and
yeah give me these buffs and let's just
eradicate some demon ass however the
cheats do not work on the Slayer gates
which there's a reason I love the Slayer
gates no getting around it you just got
to do it it does have multiplayer which
I kind of I dabbled with the multiplayer
admittedly I didn't really dive into it
it's actually a really interesting
multiplayer though it's one person's the
doom Slayer to other players pick their
demon of choice and then they do a level
and the demons try to kill the doom
Slayer and vice versa it's just a little
more unique
interesting then all right just PvP you
know five-on-five capture the flag
captured the bases cuz that's not
everywhere haven't seen that you know a
metric [ __ ] Tilian times but whatever I
play PvP I get my balls kicked in I just
find out how much I suck at these games
funny I can [ __ ] up the computer no
problem clear out those rooms no cheats
necessary PvP well I'm dead that's cool
so wish I had more to talk about PvP but
I just I buy these games for the
single-player campaign it's just how I
am there were a couple of things that
compromise the pacing the first time I
ran into him one of which was one of the
levels has a water puzzle is like oh
it's not a water level it's a sewer
based puzzle it's a water puzzle but the
water is poison
so it hurts you and kills you if you
don't have your radiation suit which
depletes over time so you gotta get
refills for it while you're figuring
this out and for me the game went from
intense intense shoot shoot blood ass
explosions everywhere to where's the
switch where's this I mean when you get
through it you know how to do it so when
you replay the level it's fine but the
first time I ran into it I was like and
and come to doom for the water puzzle so
it's not a big deal it's just right into
one thing I hope they patch which is
when you're using the weapon that runs
out of ammo the game automatically
selects another gun for you I think it's
the other gun in your car one quick
select I don't know doesn't matter point
is it should never be the BFG because
when you're in a firefight your eye
isn't on the ammo so there were two
separate occasions it was just like out
of ammo BFG but it was like hey there's
a wasted BFG shot one of my toots I'm
not saying they're diamonds I'm saying
BFG ammo is an item that you have to
find in certain select levels not as
though they're falling out of enemies
finding them in explosive barrels or
anything again an annoyance a big thing
that got me rage quitting a few times
the Marauder [ __ ] him dude it's a dick I
mean granted you adapt to survive you
will figure out how to beat him in a way
that you run across and when the game
throw
Matthieu a couple more times a few more
times you're like ah Murata okay this is
a tough fight but I'll do it but the
first couple times I ran into this guy I
didn't have any extra lives because you
get extra lives in this game so the
pattern up through the first couple
Marauder encounters was I got an extra
life in a room alright well now I died
so now I'm not operating with any extra
lives enter the Marauder this guy you
can't just shoot him bullets deflect off
of him if you're too close he's gonna
shotgun blast you if you're too far he's
gonna throw an axe at you you have to
stand in this Goldilocks zone where his
eyes blink and then he swings an axe at
you that's when you can shoot him also
remember when I said the game is really
fast and aggressive he's the most fast
and the most aggressive not just fast
and aggressive he's like zero shifting
like he's Anubis from zone of the enders
or some [ __ ] zig zagging so it's hard to
actually have him come at you straight
on that was the thing I was like this
guy's killing the momentum of the game
because I am dying couple times I turned
off my ps4 like I was Cameron Frye
sitting in his car and Ferris Bueller's
Day Off turn off the ps4
it wasn't unlike that I hated the
Marauder I was like he's different than
all the other mechanics in the game why
the [ __ ] is he here gotta hit him when
his eyes blink when he's swinging at you
he's a punch-out opponent essentially
he's not a doom demon but when you stick
with it you learn his pattern you just
you end up seeing him as an element in
the game that does change it up another
element in the game that changes it
crazy time so if a thing locks you up in
this game keep at it you're gonna be a
beast by the end guys in the end doom
eternal was everything the 2016 doom was
but faster more aggressive but I would
also argue more polished in here the
game gives you enough to survive you
just gotta learn how to implement
everything and I do mean everything and
that's a point nothing in this game
really goes to waste the level designs
are interesting the graphics are insane
the backdrops are gorgeous the weapons
are a lot of fun the encounters are
intense play this game if you love that
feeling of adrenaline if you love that
fight or flight without the flight cuz
that's just not an option some great end
game exploration I love 2016 doom I love
doom eternal I hope they keep going in
the vein of this and doom eternal
absolutely is awesome tacular
[Music]
and now I'd like to thank the sponsor of
this video this video is brought to you
by Ray con ray cons are slick stylish
true wireless earbuds that started about
half the price of other premium wireless
earbuds on the market and they sound
great their newest model e 25 s has 6
hours of playtime seamless bluetooth
pairing more bass in a more compact
design that gives you a nice noise
isolating fit and they come in a variety
of new fun colors in fact I've set it on
here before my Ray cons are my workout
headphones and they've yet to fall out
of my ears while working out we're going
for a record the wonder the
circumstances I feel it's important to
emphasize work out at home there is that
too the perfect for that or if you're
just sitting at home listening to music
perfect for that too so click the link
below in the description to get yourself
15% off your order and once again thank
you to Rea Khan for sponsoring this
video especially among everything it
really helps me out and I do appreciate
it so thank you or it's a doom eternal
have you played it what did you think
about it how does it compare to the 2016
doom for you whatever you think comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more
and
[Music]
you